welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Boston Captain America the Winter
Soldier gave marble its perfect formula
of impassioned heroism interconnected
fanservice and jaw-dropping disguises
while it's not hard to find greatness in
this film let us dive back in for its
mini secrets and easter eggs because
trust in the first glance is never
enough last time I trusted someone I
lost enough I know Nick we're home the
film opens with Steve Rogers meeting Sam
Wilson future POW kid this bit is called
back at the end on your last aunt Sam
flips it and ventures endgame on your
left and at the end of that film Sam
approaches camp
on his left both of these guys are
veterans trying to make sense of their
lives back home and again again this
film asks what it means to be a good
soldier this movie's title the Winter
Soldier describes of course Bucky
Florence hydras assassin but it's deeper
history is a quote from an 18th century
philosopher Thomas Paine inspiration to
America's founding fathers these of the
times that try men's souls the summer
soldier in the sunshine patriot will in
this crisis shrink from the service of
their country but heed the Winter
Soldier that stands by it now deserves
the love and thanks of men and women
Steve Rogers evolves from a summer
soldier Boy Scout into a morally clouded
winter soldier a loyal frostbitten
warrior who fights for its country even
when it doesn't fight for him and we
will see exactly what qualities make
Steve Rogers this film's true Winter
Soldier Steve adds Marvin Gaye's trouble
man soundtrack to his to-do list I Love
Lucy moon landing Berlin Wall Steve Jobs
disco Thai food Star Wars and Trek
nirvana and rocky international versions
of this movie actually swap out the
references like the UK list includes
Sherlock the Beatles and the 66 World
Cup final Sean Connery every country's
got their own list cap joins Natasha
Romanov on a rescue mission of the
Lemurian star weirdly misspelled on a
monitor here and weirdly mispronounced
by most of the people in this movie
launch platform Aryan Star open Lemurian
star satellite lodge file a Zola's
algorithm was on the Lou Marion star but
it is spelled right on Nats computer
later the name Lemurian is referenced to
Lemuria
a rival country to Atlantis in marble
comics connected to the deviants who are
going to be coming up soon in the
upcoming eternals film they're going
after batch rock based on the Marvel
villain Batroc the leaper
he wears purple and yellow here as bat
dog does in the comics on caps team is
Brock rumlow
who appears later with crossed straps
nodding to his future identity as Marvel
villain crossbones injured in this movie
and of course returning and civil war
caps new blue and white strike stealth
suit evokes his Secret Avengers they
receive from the comics he leaps out
with no a parachute and not to the big
moment in the Ultimate Comics now in the
past cap shield was a defensive tool but
here it is mostly offensive and how cap
doesn't fire a single bullet in the
scene or in the home movie in fact the
first of his supposed to die via gunshot
was a shot not from him but from rumlow
who is a secret baddie and when that
truck throws the grenade cap grabs an ad
to leap out that moves just fast enough
to shoot out the glass to weaken its
integrity before they hit it back in
shield fancy new Triskelion headquarters
cap and fury argue so just trust each
other that's what makes you too normal
not a bunch of guys running around
shooting guns last time I trusted
someone I lost an hour there of course
Captain Marvel later reveals that it was
goose and the flirtin that scratched out
Fury's eye when he lifts a patch later
it does look like a kitty cat scratch
but in this exchange cap also gives us
our first answer to this good soldier
question trust is what separates an army
from tough guys with guns and on the
coolest elevator in the world
fury talks about his grandfather an
elevator operator apparently based on
Jackson's actual grandfather you ever
get mugged every week some punk would
say what's in the bag
each owned a bunch of crumpled ones and
a loaded 22 Magnum and s fury story gets
darker and darker the elevator drops
lower and lower in a moment he brings up
the hidden gun they arrive at Fury's
hidden weaponry and he reveals project
insight continuous suborbital flight
courtesy of new repulsor injuries Stark
I had a few suggestions once he got an
up-close look at our old turbines that
up-close look refers to Tony getting
knocked around in the turbine rotors
back in the Avengers no rotors and cap
doesn't trust it i holding a gun to
everyone on earth and calling it
protection only Captain America as a man
displaced in time 70 years can see how
shield has evolved exactly into what the
Hydra he fought aim to be from our point
of view the world evolved slowly to hail
Hydra but for cap it was an overnight
morale about-face caps got an exhibit at
the Smithsonian narrated by actor Gary
Sinise Captain America
and his Howling Commandos quickly earned
their stripes and a good thing they
didn't use to nice is audio is
Lieutenant Dan they Avengers director
Joss Whedon cameos on the escalator
there and that's the Russo brothers
nephew Dante who somehow sees right
through caps disguise of a hat actually
Chris Evans it's a this makes sense
since kids would be able to see his face
from a lower vantage point and then when
he meets with Peggy everything she says
reframe Steve's motivation and endgame I
have lived in life my only regret is
that you didn't live yours go back and
start over live my life I'll keep that
mind for when Tony and ant-man event
time travel even Peggy's dementia is
probably what her younger self said when
Steve walked back to her door at support
group the woman is the Russos sister
Angela and Sam tell Steve about having
to watch these wingman Riley died so I
was up there just to watch just like how
Steve was up on the train just to watch
Bucky fall Fury is targeted for
assassination Nick Fury's car actually
flies in the comics as does agent
Coulson's car modelled from Howard
Starks hovering car this amazing
shootout was shot in downtown Cleveland
the same place they shot the Avengers in
fact the bank where Hydra keeps Bucky is
the same building cap jumps out up in
the Battle of New York Cleveland Metro
bus six three eight eight shows up a few
times in this movie and when the Winter
Soldier appears notice his music
the composer henry jackman uses this
horrific scratchy wail throughout the
film
to create the sound Jackman actually
used Bucky's death screen from cap one
and then distorted it so that way all of
Bucky's rage in this movie is really
just distorted echoes from the moment he
was ripped from Steve Steve meets the
nurse next door little clue here for the
reveal and some war that Sharon is
actually Sharon Carter and her insomniac
aunt is Peggy Carter sure and she's got
dementia go easy on her fury signal
Steve I'm leaving the music on in this
apartment
yes they brought this back as the final
music that cap and Peggy danced to an
end game it's been a long long time was
popular after World War two among
soldiers returning for more on Steve
Shaffer several books on war in politics
but notice all the President's Men At
Woodward and Bernstein's story of their
Watergate investigation and later right
before the elevator Steve is framed
Whitney Watergate Hotel in the
background and all the president's men
Robert Redford played Woodward Kevin
Feige called this movie a 1970s
political thriller masquerading as a big
super era movie Redford now plays the
corrupt secretary Pierce in Captain
America is now the noble sleuth asking
the right questions to eventually bring
him down just like he brought down Nixon
but here if Yuri tells cap my wife
[Music]
looking back we have to wonder if fury
does have a secret wife maybe even a
scroll one given his friendliness within
Captain Marvel like Talos posed in his
fury and far from home opened up a lot
of total conspiracies perhaps explaining
Fury's fake death in this movie because
you think cap and Natasha wouldn't know
if someone died in front of them also
there's some details like cap calls him
Nick in this movie and Captain Marvel he
said that people only call him Fury and
when scroll comes Nicholas oh he knows
you scroll although there's that whole
slice bread detail that I'll talk about
when we get to age of Ultron really the
point is Fury is a shifty dude who could
be using squirrel decoys at any point
that we see him not ambiguity is part of
what makes him so great fury its shot
and Charon calls it in Foxtrot his own
notice the shield dispatcher knows Fury
was shot without fury saying it another
clue that shield Hydra was in on this
the surgeon who operates on Fury is a
cameo by co-director Joe Russo he came
he was in all their movies like cap and
attach of what the only intended
audience being fooled by Fury's fake
death hiding them in the shadows he can
see Sitwell and rumlow watching too Matt
doesn't trust cap I was fury in your
apartment you're a terrible liar in the
following scene Pierce actually asked
the same question but Steve improves his
lying game captain why was Nick in your
apartment last night
Pierce mentions Fury's past in Bogota a
tradition of B city assignments for fury
we're be able to Captain Marvel Belfast
Bucharest Belgrade Budapest I like to be
and bat rocks interrogation is conducted
by cameos by the screenwriters Marcus
Simic feely ok so back to the coolest
elevator in the world just as the
elevator reflected the danger of Nick
Fury's grandpa's world now the
environment gets more and more dangerous
the lower the elevator plunges with each
floor whooshing past louder and louder
kind of like a heartbeat thank you and
cat picks up on all the clues the hand
on the gun the odd suitcase handle
that's actually a magnetic cuff the bead
of sweat some of these guys been
straight-up murderers but notice that
cap legit tries to avoid violence before
we get started does anyone want to get
out another facet of what makes a good
soldier that is why when cat finds
himself back in this same scenario and
of interest in game it's not the fight
that he Reese stages but the peaceful
alternative
cap kicks lippisch shield a move that we
see taskmaster doing Black Widow Sitwell
is watching on the security camera
perhaps the recording that taskmaster
uses cap escapes and finds NAT who shows
in the SCAR where Bucky shot through her
to kill a target airbrushed her on those
Ironman to glamour shots need to raise
its actual where is this necklace with
an arrow pendant a nod to her just
friendship with Hawkeye and the Apple
Store comedian DC Pierson makes a cameo
as directors on sitcoms like community
and Arrested Development the Russo sneak
in a lot of comedy cameos in their
movies Danny Pudi is a shield tech here
Jim rash and a Bluth staircar show up in
Civil War a blue man shows up in a
affinity war and kim jong-in event
Nicole Brown show up an in-game they
returned to camp Lehi the place where
cap trained in the first film cap
briefly sees a ghostly memory of himself
gawking up at him like the museum kid
but if you think about it in that memory
skinny steve was probably gawking at
Peggy Carter photos of Peggy and Colonel
Phillips and Howard Stark appeared and
the code on the door is eight five three
nine which some reaches on reddit we're
looking oh oh oh that's a release date
of Jo Simon's comic patriot number three
and to ever my guy who gets actual
confirmation from ncu directors about
comic references hit on license plates
they really only go to this trouble when
it's relevant to the story like real
eggs ain't random NAT says how he
playing a game from a movie that she's
reenacting the scene in wargames when
they talked to the computer shall we
a computer that also has an AI algorithm
toying with geopolitics in apokoliptic
weaponry
Arnim as Zola returns an algorithm for
him ghost in the code a much cooler
version of his projective based on an
Android body from the comics when
in-game visits this location the 1970
Howard Stark is looking for Zola and the
VFX artist snuck his green face on a
screen deep in the basement background
Zola reveals Hydra was behind the deaths
of Howard in Maria's stark a detail that
plays a huge role in civil war notice a
newspaper date December 17th nights in
anyone they died on the 16th but the
newspaper would have come out until the
next day Zola tells cap it's better this
way we are both of us out of time
this present-day life is a grotesque
post-apocalyptic perversion of the life
he had in the 40s Hydra is now shield
Piggy's old Bucky's evil Zola's green is
starting to sound pretty good we
watching a great movie like this makes
me appreciate the filmmaking process and
the impact of great attention to detail
and folks now is a better time than ever
to take a class and learn more about
this craft and thanks to Skillshare for
sponsoring this video make 2020 a year
where you explore new skills deepen
existing passions get lost in creativity
with skill shares online classes what
you find might just surprise and inspire
you Skillshare is an online learning
community that offers membership with
meaning with so much to explore real
projects to create and they support a
fellow creative skill sure empowers you
to accomplish real growth Skillshare
offers classes designed for real life so
you can move your creative journey
forward without putting life on hold you
can learn and grow with short classes
that fit your busy routine they have
classes and topics new rockstars fans
will enjoy like animation film and video
and creative writing a class I want to
check out is their original storytelling
in film using cinematography to convey
emotion taught by a director of
photography Joe Simon Skillshare is also
incredibly affordable to join especially
when compared to pricy in-person classes
and workshops an annual subscription of
Skillshare is less than 10 bucks a month
the first 500 of my subscribers to click
the link in the description will get a 2
month free trial of premium membership
so that you can explore your creativity
with Skillshare okay in Pearce's fridge
there's a bottle of Newman's Own a sauce
the brand of Paul Newman Robert
Redford's longtime acting partner they
regroup with Sam and interrogate Sitwell
coming out of a meeting with Senator
Stern from Iron Man 2 it's got a creepy
whisper
just glad he didn't do Odin's whisperer
Sitwell spills beans after getting a
gravity swirly solidago it's a program
for choosing insects talk West targets
you a TV anchor Cairo the undersecretary
defends a high school valedictorian Iowa
City Bruce Banner Stephen strange anyone
who's a threat to Hydra
now in the future oh I hear a threat
down Bruce Banner you know but also our
first shout-out to dr. strange the MCU
now strange doesn't become a sorcerer
until two years later but hydras
algorithm could predict this brilliant
surgeon would be a threat in the future
now some say the TV anchor in Cairo
could refer to moon at night who is
getting a Disney Plus series but this
might be a Gyptian setting marc spector
probably wouldn't work as a TV anchor my
guess is this is a reference to the
egyptian media during the Arab Spring
who were often targeted it's very big
deal when this movie was written now the
valedictorian in Iowa City
could be Amadeus Cho a teenager and
eighth smartest person in the world who
succeeds Bruce Banner as the Hulk so
when her soldier kills Sitwell that
moves quickly again if you notice she
dives in the cap while kicking sand to
the side saving both of them from
Bucky's head shots that go into their
headrests Sam also gets a cool move he
cuts the soldiers rappelling line and
the rifle sling so that he can kick the
dude off the bridge Wow keeping his
rifle in one move there are some great
recreated visuals from the comics Bucky
punching cap shield and when he gets
unmasked he asks okey Maria Hill and dr.
Joe Russo revealed fury faked his death
slow eNOS heart rate with get to the
toxin B slows the pulse to one beat a
minute
Benna developed interest dress so yeah
Bruce Banner has been continuing his
research for a balance that will
culminate with his smart talk form in
endgame and we learned via flashback
that Hydra continued Zola's super
soldier experiments on Bucky replacing
his arm with a new one another instance
of Kevin Feige scree po-2 Star Wars
amputations in every face to film roll a
cliff
[Music]
one of the Hydra scientist is a cameo by
Ed Brubaker writer of the Winter Soldier
comics Steve gets back his World War 2
era suit from the museum getting Stanley
fired an earlier scene was actually cut
showing Steve ditching his strike suit
at a basketball gym to blur off Hydra
chasing its locator chip
that's the close-up of his new kicks at
the hospital mat infiltrates Pierce's
group in disguise notice she does not
simply champagne when the others do and
when she removes the mesh mask the
material is also on her hands and her
arms so that she wouldn't have young
hands with her old face Sharon Carter
and agent Klein refused to launch in
sight another instance of this good
soldier debate Sam even asked this
question explicitly in the next scene
how do we know that good guys from the
bad guys if the shooting at you they're
bad yes when you do not know who to
trust the ones a shooting at you are not
your soldiers rumlow forces incites
launch in Zola's algorithm targets
hundreds of thousands of names some
interesting ones pop up here so let's do
a tractor horn okay there's Maria Hill
and then a bunch of generic names in the
DC area some NFL fans on reddit have
speculated that they use variations of
names of football players but we see
president Matthew Ellis from Iron Man 3
and the museum quote earlier is also a
target he's in the Capitol building but
interesting since typically the
president United States isn't in the
capitol building unless they're formally
invited by Congress separation of powers
thing characters Jeremy Irons is also on
the list maybe the famous actor maybe
does another Jeremy Irons in HBO's
Watchmen Jeremy Irons character helps
get President Robert Redford elected and
now he's on Redford's characters kill
list there's so much dusters and Anthony
stark is on the list space is also
visible there he is an Avengers tower in
New York with this being the first
glimpse of the new redesigned tower that
we see an age of Ultron and the officer
says 500 an odd of course to Tarkin and
Star Wars who gives the same casually
genocidal command on the Death Star
you may fire when ready what cap puts
Bucky in a headlock the same way his
younger self will pin him and in game
which is why cap remembers Bucky in that
moment [ __ ]
[Music]
Tapp complete submission but he stays
because he hears a familiar sound
Lucky's scream one that has been echoing
and past mine for decades but now human
once more so the Winter Soldier saves
the Winter Soldier who then returns the
favor another quality that makes a good
soldier kappa brings up this quality in
age of Ultron this is shield this is
what shields supposed cap wakes up in
the hospital bed on Sam's left and
Marvin Gaye's Trouble Man returns fury
goes off the grid by burning all his
stuff including a work permit for
Thailand considering his be City
preference I'm guessing his assignment
was a Bangkok Fury's great stone
includes the Bible verse Ezekiel 25:17
of course Sam Jackson's famous quote
from Pulp Fiction in the first post
credits scene shows hydras Baron von
Strucker with Loki's scepter and the
twins not strucker's twins from Marvel
Comics but the Maximoff twins
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch wind up
more bits these wooden blocks like
planets but then smashes them together
perhaps foreshadowing the way she'll
smashed worlds together in one division
as Marvel explores the multiverse the
final post-credits scene returns to the
museum with caps and naked mannequin now
just removed in the mannequin a Bucky
front-and-center the final sound another
distorted Winter Soldier screen
caps final act in this film it's to go
find Bucky to bring him home the final
value of a good soldier that mission
will turn cap against the other Avengers
and against his own country and Civil
War a war that will leave him shield
lists bearded without a flag left out in
the cold but fighting on a Winter
Soldier how does Captain America the
Winter Soldier rank for you in the
affinity saga is it number one we'll see
it might end up being that for me after
I get done with this series but comment
down below with your ranking and be sure
to join our future infinity saga watch
Alone's on this score by becoming a
patreon at patreon.com slash new
rockstars follow me on instagram twitter
ID a boss follow new rock stars in
subscribed into rock stars for our next
free watch where James Gunn teaches us
how to respond to every shitty comments
I'm sorry I didn't know how this machine
worked
[Music]